ihab a turismo
o tengo un sueño
ese fue el título del discurso de un
hombre que hizo o que logró movilizar a
250.000 personas en eeuu que caminaron
por kilómetros hasta llegar a washington
para dar un discurso en contra de la
desigualdad y la segregación
este hombre fue martin luther king y si
se preguntan
si era necesario hacer cosas para que
era una manifestación tan grande que se
logró con eso
bueno
aparte de que de que se lograra la nueva
acta de derechos civiles conocida como
es ahora este hombre se ganó el premio
nobel de la paz siendo también la
persona más joven en ganarse ese premio
para entonces pero hubo otro bastante
icónico que decía algo parecido a esto
porque los hombres y mujeres de piel
blanca con los ojos azules y el pelo
rubio en ellos reside el gen de la
perfección ellos son los perfectos ellos
son descendientes de la raza aria
es ser adolfo hitler un hombre que con
el poder de su voz y con la fuerza de
sus convicciones instauró en lo más
profundo de mucha gente ideas y
creencias que perduran hasta nuestros
días en algunos países de europa
pero
si ven a estos hombres al igual que
tantos otros y otras compartían algo en
común y es a lo que yo llamo un
superpoder y ese es el poder de la
palabra porque la palabra con la palabra
se construye o se destruye las palabras
crean la guerra o hacen la paz la
familia se une o se deshace
con las palabras nos convertimos en
magos de magia blanco de magia negra y
todo porque precisamente tiene mucho
poder de influencia en la emocionalidad
de la gente
pero ellos compartían otro superpoder y
es a lo que yo llamo el poder de su
historia gente como lincoln gandhi
mándela quin hitler ellos se entendían a
la perfección lo que el pueblo decía
quería y sentir
por qué
ellos mismos habían vivido las mismas
situaciones bajo las mismas condiciones
entonces eso les permitía hablar no
solamente de esta era desde la ideal
sino también desde la experiencia
cuántos caminos tuvieron que atravesar
cuántos a cuánto dolor tuvieron que
soportar cuántas caídas y levantadas
cuántos actos de valentía y de
resiliencia
y eso es precisamente lo que nos hizo
trascender lo que nos hace recordarlos y
lo que nos hace citar los casi de forma
obligatoria
entonces esa es la idea que quiero
compartir con ustedes hoy
el poder que tienen las historias para
cambiar el mundo
ahora bien la razón por la que yo estoy
aquí parado frente a usted es la razón
por la que te era ex enteró que yo
existía está enfrascada en dos historias
primera historia cuando yo de alguna
forma me enteré cuando me di cuenta que
mi camino que mi llamado tenía que ver
con esto de que quería hablar en público
que quería ser un conferencista y todo
eso para entonces yo estaba en la
universidad y
no tenía ninguna motivación no me
interesaba no me gustaba por ejemplo la
lectura odiaba la lectura
no tenía ninguna dirección yo estudiaba
allí estudia administración de empresas
y para mí no tenía ningún sentido en ese
momento
hasta el día que asistí a una
conferencia de un hombre que con cada
palabra que dijo me cambió la vida pero
para siempre ahora si me preguntan quién
era ese hombre que fue tiempo esa
persona
no me acuerdo absolutamente nada para
nada de su nombre
entonces ya person que fue lo
espectacular que dijo que te cambió la
vida
tampoco me recuerdo no recuerdo una sola
palabra de lo que ese señor dijo ahora
lo que yo sí recuerdo es como lo dijo
este hombre hablaba con tanta serenidad
con una con tanta sabiduría con tanta
elocuencia
que me inspiró a decir sabes que yo
quiero hablar como yo quiero lograr eso
que todavía no lo logro pero voy a
ramones
entonces
de alguna manera de alguna manera
[Música]
todo empezó a
a ponerse en su sitio yo empiezo a
asistir a charlas
como un taller de oratoria
llegaste tú axa mi vida incluso le
pregunto al amigo de mi hermano que era
conferencista oye que se necesita para
ser un buen conferencista él me dice lo
primero que tienes que hacer es leer
mucho y en automático yo empiezo a
quitarme de la idea porque
definitivamente no me gustaba me dormía
me aburría y ya no sentía como que el
tema conferencia ya no era lo mío hoy en
que el nivel de mediocridad yo estaba
manejando entonces esa fue la primera
historia segunda historia
un día estaba yo dando mi clase yo soy
instructor de clases de clases grupales
y ellos tienen eliminadas instruyendo
les digo señores miren esto lo que va a
pasar enganchen aquí y pongan aquí de
repente
y entonces caigo en el piso
me desmayo
mis signos vitales estaban bien pero yo
no podía acceder a ellos
yo escuchaba que me hablaban jefferson
jefferson pero yo no no podía responder
no tenía fuerza para ni siquiera mover
la lengua para decir algo yo sentía que
manipulaban que me movían pero yo no
podía moverme por mí mismo
entonces ya vengo me mejor voy al médico
y me hago unos estudios
me llama el doctor a su consultorio y
éste me da un diagnóstico que para mí
fue fatal me dijo
señor usted tiene
un tumor cerebral
todos esos y a todos esos mareos que le
estaban dando previos al desmayo fueron
una serie de micro infartos cerebrales
para mí eso fue devastador fue aterrador
y hasta un poco frustrante porque yo
decía cómo es posible que un muchacho
joven y que le gusta hacer ejercicio
como es posible que le pasen estas cosas
pero gracias a dios pues fue un tumor
benigno vélez ahora bien que es lo
interesante de todo esto
durante mi recuperación yo no podía usar
teléfono celular no podía usar
computadoras no podía ver televisión
porque el brillo de las pantallas me
podía hacer daño no podía tener una
persona acompañándome hablándome el día
entero porque imagínate no podía haber
una persona en esa entonces cuál era la
única el único entretenimiento que yo
tenía
y ahí fue
fue en el momento en donde me casé con
una frase que dice hay bendición detrás
de la maldición
y donde me encontré con otra frase que
dice que el maestro siempre ha estado
pero aparece cuando el alumno está listo
me di cuenta que
que disfrutaba más de la lectura de
cuentos de metáforas de reflexiones ese
tipo de cosas
y que cuando la casa se volvía muy
ruidosa pues yo me iba al techo y allí
cuando me encontraba conmigo mismo y el
silencio pues ahí las ideas fluían más
mi inspiración era como más grande
y bueno ya la idea de ser un
conferencista volvió a mí y de nuevo
esas son el tipo de cosas que
que nos quedan y eso es precisamente lo
que quiero que coloque con lo que quiero
que ustedes se queden
en algún momento de d
bueno mientras estaba en este esperando
en el camino de todo lo que iba a pasar
con mi vida también me doy cuenta
descubro
o investigo que las civilizaciones y
culturas ancestrales utilizaban el tema
historias utilizaban las historias
como ellos habían descubierto que había
un poder superior en todo esto había un
conocimiento que les permitía no
solamente
tocar la fibra emocional de cada persona
sino también a crear mucha empatía y
entonces ellos utilizaban esta esto de
las historias no solamente como
entretenimiento sino como una
herramienta yo soy
muy creyente de que de que podemos
cambiar el mundo a través de este tipo
de práctica entonces a raíz de todo eso
es que se me ocurre y salgo con la idea
de crear un evento un proyecto que yo
llamo desde mi techo
desde mi techo es un espacio que se abre
para contar historias inspiradoras
historias que cambien
sin importar que sean historias reales o
metáforas siempre y cuando lleven a la
reflexión y al aprendizaje
viendo también el impacto que tuvo esto
en que la gente se sentía muy tocada por
el poder por el evento me di cuenta o se
me ocurrió que habían otros otros
espacios otros
otros
partes de la sociedad que podían ser
beneficiados por esto tales como las
cárceles las escuelas públicas y las
mujeres entonces por ahí se me ocurre
hacer desde mi techo labor social
al principio de este año fuimos a la
fuimos a la cárcel de rafey rafey en
santiago hicimos el evento allá y fue
impresionante ver como tanto bueno
alrededor de 70 u 80 hombres de los
internos que estaban ahí como ellos la
mayoría no pudieron aguantar las
lágrimas porque se sentían puramente
conectados con lo que estábamos contando
para ellos
fue impresionante ver eso entonces
yo creo y soy un fiel creyente de que
tus historias pasadas te trajeron a tu
situación actual pero tu situación
actual no define tus historias futuras
entonces para terminar
quisiera que me acompañarán con esto
agárrese una hebra de cabello de la
cabeza a mí va a ser un poco difícil
porque imagínate
una sola intenten eso una sola
una sola hebra de cabello asegúrese que
sea una y si no hay en la cabeza porque
se en un brazo
si no hay un brazo la pierna se me
acaban las opciones
encuentren uno si ya lo tienen
si ahora arranca te lo hará que este
sitio
se sintió
ahora explicaba vamos a traducir esto
como es posible como es posible que en
una cabeza llena de cabello se sienta
cuando se sale un solo cabello
imaginemos ahora que la cabeza es el
mundo y que cada cabello cada cabello
somos nosotros significa que tus
acciones cada acción que tú decidas
tomar de alguna forma va a tomar va a
tener una incidencia en el resto del
mundo cuando nosotros hablamos de
cambiar el mundo no me refiero
exactamente en cambiar al planeta tierra
pero sí puede ser cambiar a tu país
cambiará tu ciudad cambiará tu comunidad
cambiar tu círculo laboral tu círculo
familiar
entonces
les invito incluso perdón incluso
cambiar a uno solo cambiar a uno solo es
suficiente porque dicen que cada cabeza
es un mundo
y si podemos cambiar a uno bueno pues lo
hemos hecho así que
yo les invito a que crean
como yo que literalmente creo que todos
juntos podemos cambiar el mundo y
podemos hacerlo
un cabello a la vez